[Music]
I need like a hammock today man we'll
see if I can stay on the stool it's been
a long time some words to life yeah it's
a trigger word you can always get up for
an emergency evacuation but a long time
said to fight this hard so what are we
talking about stage first of all episode
500 I could think of no two better
people or the two people that I wanted
to do this with and you guys we are
reprising our New York City hotel room
encounter from like sitting on a guy's
not like a [ __ ] like me right like 610
or whatever you and shout out to Mishka
who's experiencing a little Montezuma's
Revenge Timon clear whether you were
gonna post up today but you made it yeah
I told you're up man that's it there was
there was no point where I was like I'm
gonna bail on the podcast but there was
one point last night where I was like if
I just die then the rich won't be mad
for me right you were texting me
yesterday about how bad it was and I was
like well this is perfect because it
basically just creates a platform to
deconstruct the you know sort of
trashcan fire that is your life what one
thing I will say is man like remember
when you used to drink yourself to this
point of illness on a regular basis
constantly like dude I can't I can't
[ __ ] believe I used to live like this
man like I you know this last four days
it's just been like a drug trip I go out
of your way that way yeah yes that you
would go pay to pay to feel ya know ship
em so welcome boys thank you thanks for
having yeah man horse-like to the
podcast is like going through the
stratosphere like it's been on the
guests that a journey man it's bad
terney don't you guys go back swell
those are the oh geez you go back all
the way to the beginning so decided to
have you that was one of the things I
was thinking when I was like biting my
tongue on the way here to like stay in
my lane to get here is that like this is
a hell of a trip you've taken man you
know from like from being a drunk which
is like the ultimate in narcissism you
know where you just take yourself out of
the game completely just following your
own pleasure or self obsession to this
thing that you've created man of just
like going so deep into the life of the
mind and how much you've given to me -
John - [ __ ] every world I was telling
the goober guy he's like so what are you
in LA to do I said oh you know I'm going
up to do this podcast I was telling him
about it and he's like oh yeah well I go
yeah you know this is somebody that is
living a life of service you know to
others with you know the amount of
people that the podcast has helped you
know it's it's I'm not just blowing
smoke up your ass man I get like [ __ ]
hundreds of letters a month of it you
know that people just went down the
rabbit hole in your podcast cuz you just
cover everything and not just you know
vegan people or whatever it's just real
people that are pushing the envelope
challenging themselves overcoming
obstacles and just like it's you know I
listen to probably just about every yeah
you know I mean it was it was humble
beginnings I've said it before but when
I started it you know I didn't know if I
would do a second episode I was just
doing it for fun and following my
curiosity and it's just kind of
organically grown from there you know
wasn't it wasn't the result of deciding
this is gonna be my vocation or like
whiteboarding it or creating goals or
this is what I want it to be I honestly
just showed up for it you know every
week and it's just kind of come what
it's what has become and look you know
there's there's luck involved - like I
was in the right place at the right time
and this medium kind of blew up and I've
been doing it for a little bit but you
know it's just been such a gift and you
know to your point of like Mischka of
like you know being this narcissistic
alcoholic on a path
self-destruction - one of one of service
and yeah you know first of all like I'm
still selfish bastard prune to my you
know ego and and and the victim of a
million different character defects but
but what I have learned in the hallowed
halls of recovery that you so
vociferously shine is the value of
service and how and how you know when
you can orient your life or approach
certain circumstances or situations that
you find yourself in from a perspective
of service and what you can give as
opposed to what you can extract from it
that your life goes better and actually
you're you're happier so I try to enter
into all of these with with that mindset
right I was that was my exact
conversation you know this guy came up
from Mexico he's you know left a career
they wanted him to be a doctor and he's
like I just wasn't happy doing it and
you know it's just helping other people
service to people is I mean I found my
happiness lies in that too it's but let
me ask you this was he listening to the
radio no I've never gotten into an uber
or lyft where they were listening to a
podcast so I'm always like hey here's
the podcast they're like yeah I don't
really know what that and you know it's
weird it's like you're driving around
all day you would think more but you
know watch Sharpie he told me that's
what he does he listens to meditation
podcasts and and puts them on for people
and that's cool he actually got out of
the car to pet your dog he's like who's
this beautiful creature but like I
talked to him about you know diet and
stuff - we we had a good talk the whole
time I wasn't sitting there like a
[ __ ] you know it's a stretcher yeah
you know he's like well you know I stay
plant-based but then when I go to my
relatives in Mexico then they that's
what they make for me
you know whatever mmm went down the
rabbit hole on that one the the best
advice I ever got in my life was from a
taxi driver like 15 years ago or
something of course and he said
everybody's got to work but you get to
decide who you work for and he was like
me I work for me you know and now that
blew my [ __ ] mind you know cuz like
mmm who's just like everybody's at that
time in New York everybody's working for
startups and like you know you know you
gotta have you gotta have the money you
know just this like naked fetishization
of wealth and then I was like not I I
could just work for me and like for
what's important for me you know like I
got a van outside waiting for when the
car [ __ ] would come up you I got a new
truck you're gonna love it and it's it's
awesome I saw a photo of that got rid of
the van so ninety-two men tour story
it's only 20 only 28 years old it's just
getting broken in I'm so old that when I
hear 92 I was like oh that's pretty new
it doesn't register to get to the
seventies like yeah I know so what
happened you were in Mexico yeah I was
down to Mexico visit my uncle he goes
down there every year he got sober in
Mexico he fell down hit his head and
then he liked you know he's a religious
guy and he was like I had a miracle from
Jesus and he just removed my urge to
drink Wow
and he so he's been sober 90 yeah and
and and he went to meetings and stuff he
doesn't go you know anymore but he
stayed sober and so I just go down there
you know every year to just hang out
with my uncle and like just chill out
and drink tap water oh man we're in
Mexico Sayulita which is north puerto
vallarta a little surfing village the
and it was it's great man because I was
like oh I'm gonna see rich I'm gonna see
JJ and like I've been doing good with my
diet I run again banged up ten miles the
other day like no problems didn't even
feel sore the next day and I was like oh
my stomach feels a little
[ __ ] four days later you've been laid
out pretty badly yeah yeah just like
just you know there's that like the
level of sickness where you're like am I
gonna die and then you're like please
let me die please just just let me die
you know it's like last night I was sick
enough that if there have been somebody
there for me to cry to I would have
cried sure this alone Oh friends cuz
I've I've stayed pretty close with Jay
Jay over the last couple years but I
haven't seen you in quite some time man
spent it's probably the longest since
I've known you that I've gone without
like being in in pretty close contact
with you yeah I uh sort of I sort of
went off the map for a minute there
oh I went out and did five months on the
road without a break uh-huh never do
that I never [ __ ] do that I could
have told you I never told you years ago
playing some like crazy places too so
yeah basically for people that are
listening or that are new and haven't
heard our past episodes Mischka lives
this life where you're essentially
living out of your car hitting these
dive bars and doing like gigs on the on
the nightly right just kind of driving
around the u.s. yeah across Europe I
mean the last time I saw you I think was
when when and when we're in London and
it's yeah yeah and you were playing a
little bar there but since that time
like that's basically what you've been
doing right yup just gigging out if he's
like I have holes so like what years the
20 20
so 20 18 I bought a place I sort of like
after five months I just like [ __ ]
lost my mind and I was my mama's living
in Phoenix and I was like I'm just gonna
rent an apartment there and then I
looked into it and it was cheaper to buy
a house so I bought this like
hundred-year-old house that's like
falling apart and and moved there and
then I've been trying is I've been
trying to put down roots man you know
like my mom lives down the street now
and I have a house I got a cat Wow I got
a little special needs cat how often are
you there
the I don't know man after this
after this like I got real sick when I
was in Europe last summer and then after
getting like real sick again I might be
staying home for a minute man oh I just
feel I'm not like I'm trying not to make
any big decisions right now cuz you know
like if you're super sick you've been
sick for a while
you know like it seemed just everything
goes out the window right you know your
your your image of yourself your plans
for the future your mental health all
that [ __ ] and right now I'm just like oh
yeah my life's over you know but no I
have a great year ahead of me and I've
been building a like a really good life
in Phoenix good I'm glad to hear that
man and I'm with stability I'm gonna be
taking some time off the road to do this
come on man from JJ who's been on and
off the road for how many years thirty
yeah yeah so you just wrapped a tour
recently didn't you yeah we cro-mags
were out with clutch and Killswitch and
then before that way Hatebreed uh-huh
and then we did some you know you do
these like big european we do like
you're a hardcore festival twenty-five
thirty thousand people we played up in
canada seventy-seven festival which we
we don't hit the same venue no i'm gonna
tell you right now the best [ __ ] gigs
is not when there's a barricade and
there's all these people it's that small
venue with 500 people was 300 people
packed in there and it's like you know
just going apeshit yeah knocking my
[ __ ] teeth out and whatever the [ __ ]
is no I remember seeing you guys in New
York some years back and it was like no
time had passed
you know like this [ __ ] is happening
right now yeah it is it's always just
been about the connection between the
people right I think that's what that
that's what keeps you continuing to just
like it's there's nothing like
one-on-one I mean for you they're very
intimate right like you get these kinds
of people and you know you have this
like super devoted you know interesting
like cross-section of humanity that
turns up
no see you play just Henry Rollins did a
thing on vh1 some like a year back they
still show it occasionally and he was
like I love Henry when I left the Navy I
stayed at his house with Ian MacKaye and
but he said that way back in the day
everybody
you know when you saw a band it was like
the duties on stage and you're a hundred
yards away and I was just talking with
your producer and he talking about
seeing Sabbath and everything and then
all of a sudden there's no barricade and
Henry Rollins said he went to see the
Bad Brains and I think it was 79 and HR
the singer jumped off the stage and
knocked him down and was screaming over
him into the mic and Henry just looked
at him and was like I'm gonna do this
for the rest of my [ __ ] life and
that's the energy that comes from those
types of shows you know well Henry is an
interesting dude I mean he sort of you
know now much more of like a spoken word
artist he gets up and does these one-man
show and hewed being cross you gotta get
him and he goes on these crazy world
travels where he just drops himself into
the middle of like a place he would
never choose to go just so he can like
learn about what's going on he's amazing
[ __ ] guy and you know I saw SOA one
of his earlier bands and then he
auditioned for Black Flag at the Bad
Brains studio 171 a and then his first
show with Black Flag was at the Mudd
Club and he [ __ ] came out I think it
was early 81 no [ __ ] shoes no shirt
barefoot and just [ __ ] ripped it and
I was like holy [ __ ] like but he cut his
teeth like the 9:30 club in DC yeah 9:30
and even you know had Madame's organ and
the whole scene that you know back then
it was like they would do shows just out
in the middle of wherever the [ __ ] I
remember they did this it was a big show
out in
Virginia and it was at a it was Red Sea
and a bunch of other bands and everybody
got in these bands at the the bar was
called the branding iron and we get out
there it's a [ __ ] country bar there's
tables on up to the stage with dudes
with 10-gallon hats no idea of what the
[ __ ] is about to go down and they came
on that didn't make it past two songs of
the first band everybody started
stage-diving rekt the club they called
the cops but yeah Henry you know Henry
goes way back and he'll even tell you
himself the greatest influence in that
whole scene to him was Bad Brains and
then they went those guys went out to
California and checked out the whole
West Coast scene you know the black
flags and and Circle Jerks of Dead
Kennedys and that whole thing that was
going on and then brought that whole
thing back back east so where where was
Henry when you crashed with him he was
living like outside of Georgetown I
think him and him and Ian had an
apartment in Alexandria I think it was
I'm not sure like was he black flag and
full effect or not or was he he had
taken some time off like SOA state of
alert broke up and then he was just
working at like a deli uh-huh on I think
in Georgetown and the funny [ __ ] was I
was AWOL he let me stay D I just went
from the Navy and uh it was late I
stayed there like a little over a week
and eating his food every day's I go you
gotta get the [ __ ] out the undead played
at the 9:30 club and they were from New
York so I said yo can you drive me up to
New York man and that but yeah those you
know and I talked about you know now you
get these dudes going in the mosh pit
and they're [ __ ] throwing kicks at
each other and it's like it was never
like that when I first saw it it was
like this tribal dance and you had like
a thousand people and Henry Rollins just
leading the pack like creepy crawling
around
to the dead kennedys holiday in Cambodia
and nobody would even it'd be a thousand
dudes creepy crawling and nobody would
even [ __ ] bump into each other
mhm and so what do you think it is about
him that makes him special and different
he lived his [ __ ] he's uh you know Henry
just [ __ ] live that [ __ ] he just said
though I'm gonna do this and never
[ __ ] back down he played music you
know did he has the book getting the van
and it talks all the whole [ __ ] story
about being in Black Flag and here's an
unmatched level of intensity right yes I
mean it's just like you know it's yeah
he's and he you know he was always
physically fit to started getting into
training a lot and always keeping fit
and putting you know never and what I
appreciated too was the fact that you
know he didn't get [ __ ] up and take
drugs and go on stage and make excuses
sorry for the shitty show like every
time he went he's the consummate
professional he went on stage and he
[ __ ] killed it and did did it for
year after year after year and then he
started writing the books and it was
always DIY do-it-yourself and you know
and then he in started that label you
know what do you call it down in town in
DC and started putting out all the
records they always did the [ __ ]
themselves
like even he knows the static of the
whole movement yeah it was like why
should these even with the cro-mags when
we started nobody would [ __ ] touch us
so we paid and I and went and did a
[ __ ] demo ourselves and it got all
over the country to the point where
Metallica was [ __ ] coming to see us
but we were always like [ __ ] the
establishment why are we gonna wait for
what dribbles down their [ __ ] leg
let's just go get it ourselves they're
not paying to see the label or the
manager or the whatever they're there to
see the band
so let's [ __ ] give them you know what
they came to see right you've always
been DIY yeah but I will say that this
that that jayjay talks about of like
always being there always giving 100%
that was the kind of thing that my
friends and I [ __ ] on when I was here
when I was younger and we were you know
we were like way more into like Dead
Boys and [ __ ] like that I just like you
know like that [ __ ] junkies with
guitars the detached irony and cinnamon
and you know what like you guys right
and that's like it's old
Haley crystal that used to own CBGB's
before it closed used to pay the dead
boys with a sack of hamburgers and and
and [ __ ] bundle of heroin and then
cheat and then would go out back and
[ __ ] in the artists alley behind
Seabees and [ __ ] banged open like it
was a different I saw that whole junkie
punk rock [ __ ] in the 70s my first girl
died from that from from heroin but you
know that's what I liked about discord
that's Ian's label and what those guys
all did was it was like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] sex drugs and rock'n'roll
[ __ ] like you know we're gonna
[ __ ] do it this way and and like I
said if you live that fantasy life very
few of those people first of all
survived it and second of all is still
out there doing it third of all at the
level that you could go see Henry and
he'll still kill it or blood cloud or
chrome eggs or whatever and it's like
you have to attribute that you know
speaking of which that's why you're in
LA right you're racing with this new
band or you know is the same band
unfortunately our guitar player Todd
Youth had a substance problem and he
relapsed right after the record right
after the first tour and he got some of
that fentanyl [ __ ] that's going around
and and he he died and it was [ __ ] it
was a travesty cuz he's been a friend of
mine since he first showed up on the
scene in 83 in New York he was probably
12 he ran away from a home and we had
similar similar stories so I was like
you know I was like 21 and
[ __ ] Street [ __ ] nobody
touches this [ __ ] kid like you know
and we've been in friends years and
years and years we had another band that
opened up for the Red Hot Chili Peppers
on the Mother's Milk tour so we just
been down a long road together and then
we do this album and it's everyone's
bugging the [ __ ] out it's called up in
arms and it's just like started doing so
well and then he came off tour and had
problems in his marriage and she decided
to leave and he was [ __ ] relapsed and
you know passed away it was like [ __ ]
up and we wanna go was about a year and
a half ago now so like we waited and you
know but you know it's you know we have
a responsibility in the business aspect
of like metalblade Brian Slagel [ __ ]
we got hooked up with that deal through
tal Ronan who owns crossroads he was
friends with me and Todd and heard the
demo and was like can I give this [ __ ]
to Brian Brian Slagel [ __ ] assigned us
through with Michael a Largo who Simon
Metallica got us the deal we wanted in
it just so we waited you know for this
time to audition CI this [ __ ]
don't even have to audition I don't want
to drop his name yet because we want to
wait till the band mate makes a
statement about it but he's he's a
[ __ ] virtuoso and he's been doing
this [ __ ] for a long time and we're
excited to have him in the band and me
and him wrote five or six new songs in
New York he's from New York so we've
been writing stuff and he learned the
record and yeah so initially you gotta
tell us what it is we're off he's a
monster [ __ ] guitar player it's been
in huge bands and and he's a friend and
you know it's he's clean and sober now
like any of us you know we all had our
issues and
you know soldier on man Joey Castillo
the drummer had issues and Nick had
issues all of us but you know you you're
stronger as a team than an individual so
and that's that was the thing with Todd
was he never would reveal his mind and
confidence which is one of the the
qualities of a devotee because he was a
high Krishna to was that you're supposed
to reveal your mind and comfort
confidence to you know other people on
the path and he wouldn't do that and he
would hide it from that he was using but
but that's what I like still right but
the thing is I've been down in that [ __ ]
since 76 I know when somebody's high and
I was calling him on it and then he just
caught off all [ __ ] ties he wouldn't
answer his phone like all this [ __ ] and
you know anybody that's using and
anybody that's getting high and that
that's always my messages look man you
can't [ __ ] do it alone you got it you
got to reach out for help you know
nobody's gonna judge you that's what he
thought that oh man I relapsed the
embarrassment the embarrassment could
cause death yeah if you let it you 100%
I mean that that's the number one driver
shame you know especially with somebody
who relapses who had some time or knows
what that kind of recovery community is
all about there's so much fear and shame
that prevents them from going back and I
think that it's a it's a default
instinct amongst alcoholics and addicts
to want to try to solve the problem
alone and that's driven by fear and
shame right like I don't need anybody's
help I'm not gonna tell anybody I'm just
gonna solve this and then I'll emerge
you know hole once again and that's what
drives people to you know jails
institutions and ultimately death
because it really isn't something that
you can do alone and I'm not saying that
there aren't people that have I'm sure
there are people that have gotten sober
in states over by themselves but that's
not the story that you typically hear
and I think what's interesting about the
three of us is that you know we're all
clean and sober and we all have been you
know that way for quite some time
varying lengths of time we
done it in different ways though right
so how long john like how long have you
been clean and sober well you know
speaking of the embarrassment
you know I hooked up with the Bad Brains
and then did all that [ __ ] in the early
80s and then I relapsed after eight
years 88 to 90 and I first were on crack
pills boozed the whole [ __ ] I tried to
hide it and then it just was like [ __ ]
out everybody knew and I went through
all that [ __ ] and then the 90s I said I
almost got murdered and I was like
that's it you know I'm it was real [ __ ]
you know I had a ar-15s [ __ ] you know
the whole [ __ ] it was some crazy [ __ ]
right and so I I turned to other people
and got to help you know and I I kicked
right in the neighborhood walking past
[ __ ] smoking crack like in
Alphabet City but then I got completely
sober but then I started in 898 you know
having DJ parties and doing [ __ ]
brownies and shrooms and weed shakes AJ
funk cro-mags used to call me shakes the
clown cuz I would do these like you know
vegan lattes with like weed that I
cooked in coconut oil and and I was just
getting when was this [ __ ] up 98 oh
wow I didn't know that all the way to
2010 9/11 hit and several things
happened I had to do an intervention on
my younger brother again Franco almost
died the day before 9/11 and then take
this lady called me she's like your
brother's dying you better come get him
and I had to go to Staten Island drag
him out of an attic take him to my house
had him on a flight the next day to
[ __ ] rehab and st. Thomas boom planes
hit didn't go and then all this [ __ ]
started happening and I'm like seeing
you know my father what what the his
whole alcoholism thing what it did to
the family and my mother telling me she
was raped that's how I was born it was I
just started seeing so much bad [ __ ] and
bad juju and involved around anybody
that was in my life that was you
that I was like that's [ __ ] it and I
got popped I had a weed business I was
delivering the [ __ ] Dave Chappelle
everybody I didn't know this part how
many how many hundreds of hours have I
been in conversation I had a Whelan
business I keep thinking I've like
tapped out on the number of stories that
you have I had a windy business I
started working for the Pope of pot one
eight hundred one pot but then I said
[ __ ] this I could do it myself
so I got huge modeling agencies would
call me everybody had my number
including Dave Chappelle's agent from
Tristar pictures Matt Hine so Dave
Chappelle was one of my customers and I
used to put all the weed I used to ride
a seven eight thousand dollar
professional bike put all the weed
inside a black water bottle in the cage
and I've just rode around in bike gear
like looking like I was out for a ride
and then not so you got another Ironman
[ __ ] yeah it was during the bad weather
I had somebody drive me this guy Scott
and just this freak [ __ ] happened I
would never
it was it always had to be a referral
and I had to call a person it was like
real tight I didn't just [ __ ] sell
[ __ ] on the street so it was this
[ __ ] dumb ass [ __ ] business man
dude tells me oh I met this Balcombe and
I got popped bottom line and and then AJ
Novello who was in leeway and the
cro-mags from since 92 was like he said
you know I talked to my my Swami was
this he's this incredible astrologist
from India and he'd said so much [ __ ]
that [ __ ] about people he was able to
do their charts and see the vedic
astrologer [ __ ] unbelievable from
india like the real deal and AJ said to
him should I
I'm thinking about doing this music
again the side project with my singer
and he goes yeah you can do it once he
gets out of prison because that's where
he's going and I was like
and he needs to stop doing drugs cuz
some bad stuff is in his chart and right
after AJ told me that I got busted and
then all this [ __ ] happen with you know
my brother and all this other [ __ ] and
I'm like you know what that's it
so since riot since right right around
9/11 I just I just got sober so [ __ ]
nineteen years man of you know to win
the do and not even like cuz I started
feeling like even smoking weed I had to
smoke the whole bag I had to you know
I'm an addict
I can't just I had to smoke the whole
bag of rocks of crack and then freebase
and then go rob [ __ ] to get
their [ __ ] whatever that's the way I've
always been with my addiction problem I
I would drink the whole bottle I would
take [ __ ] three Placid hills or two
nas or quaaludes or whatever the [ __ ] I
was doing and I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ]
die it's in the cards
I gotta [ __ ] stop mm-hm and then
shortly after I started you know
training for marathons and then I'm
gonna let which led to but you never
went to 12-step never but I did
nutrition the temple
I mean you you're your program of
recovery is very much a spiritual
program but it's one of your own design
yeah yeah oh but it's not isolating I
knew I couldn't do it on my own I had to
be around people with the PMA like I
always say and and you know those those
touchstones that people like yourself
and everybody else who's been through it
and done it and and are on the higher
path I I made sure that I would [ __ ]
to the point of like they'd be like
you'll dude it's kind of creepy like how
much I wanted to just I was like bro I
just need to be around positive people
like you know it was that type of thing
where I'm like it's it's either you know
everything is by association in Sanskrit
bhakta Sangan who we hang out with we
take on those qualities and I wanted the
qualities of the [ __ ] badasses on the
planet that gets [ __ ] done under any and
all circumstances and I knew it wasn't
gonna happen
I started distict distancing myself
from people who always made excuses and
you know all that other [ __ ] that always
playing the victim and all you know
always me and everyone's out there yeah
I just was like not that I don't have
compassion to try to help him but it
wasn't helping me in my life being
around those people have you ever gotten
close to a relapse since then not at all
man cuz that's why my girl didn't
understand Erica didn't understand why I
do two Ironman stuff and I'm like you
know listen man and and my coach
originally was Orion Mims and he goes
you know and he's been through [ __ ]
hell he's a [ __ ] brother he's had a
[ __ ] up family life african-american
box to all the [ __ ] and he was like you
know we're all running from dis keeps
the demons at bay you know and for me
it's like the writing the training all
of that stuff is what helps beat the
mind with a stick every day so when
someone says to you you've just replaced
one addiction for another you you you
know you stopped with the crack and the
weed and the booze etc and you've
replaced that with Ironman training like
how do you respond to that I say yeah
that and good diet what the [ __ ] like
what do you what would you rather be
someone just said that's funny enough
this is your drug and I go yeah it's my
drug of choice but guess what I get high
as [ __ ] off of it I'm in shape I help
other people and so it's weight or
you're gonna [ __ ] die like what do
you what like what's what's the
alternative to that Mischka is a good
retort to that question but well the the
thing I came up with most recently is no
I didn't just replace one addiction with
another I replaced you know in your case
the you know crack smoking you know
robber junkie with an elite athlete who
[ __ ] inspires hundreds of thousands
of people mm-hmm so people are gonna
find a way to hate on whatever you do
for some time when you got asked that
question you said the drink here's how I
think about it like the drink was always
the easy choice and putting on the
running shoes in the morning is the hard
choice yeah dude especially today well
you aren't going running today
oh man yeah the so I have an audio book
coming out in March about you know how I
quit drinking and what my process was
with Canada sorry yeah so I did a lot of
I did a lot of research into that this
whole replacing one addiction with
another it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] its
fabrication they there's been no
evidence of people who are prone to one
addiction you know having replacing one
addiction with another and what's in
fact there was no research on it until
the early 2000s and there was a a study
from 2001 to 2004 that shows that if you
had if you're an alcoholic and then you
deal with being an alcoholic you're much
less likely to have a cross addiction
you to develop a cross addiction to
something else then somebody who's still
a functional alcoholic who becomes a
dignity but fast there's something
worries counter-intuitive about that I
mean you're saying someone who deals
with their alcoholism like if you're
just a dry drunk and you've got no you
know spiritual program then in my
experience that person is much more
likely to find themselves trying to you
know alter their you know their interior
landscape by you know gambling or sex or
you know whatever it is they'll find
some other way to because you're not if
you're not dealing with the underlying
disease that feeling of disease that
feeling of like not not feeling
comfortable in your own skin you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna latch
onto some other way of like altering
your consciousness yeah I mean the you
know I have two responses to that you
know one thing is that the you know this
study it's saying you know people it's
it there's they're not comparing those
people to of you know to normal folks
that it's just comparing people who are
actively practicing or actively using
and people who are or know
or actively using so I don't think that
it's perfect data there but you know
what you what you describe it a dry
drunk with no spiritual program by your
terminology that's me bro so you've been
hit me while I'm down great that you've
been sober how long at this point ten
years now or you maybe I should say
you've abstained over a qualitative
difference yeah I mean one of the things
I wanted to you know to address you know
is I I'm not I'm not clean by that
terminology like I you know I use
mushrooms a couple times a year
infrequently I'll smoke pod or something
like that the you know more and more
though like you know I have a bag of
mushrooms in my freezer and it's been
there were eight months ten months like
I just don't have the time to get around
to doing it because I'm doing other [ __ ]
you don't sting um but I just wanted to
sort of fact check that okay well one
thing that I I look at it is and I
always said this the amount of time and
effort and energy that goes into
maintaining a habit if you redirected
that energy toward anything positive for
me it was like I'm like all the [ __ ]
that I had to go through to get the coke
exhaustive freebase it and in my case it
had to do with like strong-arm robbing
[ __ ] which could get me killed
and the amount of energy even even a
junkie who has a bundle of day habit and
I see it all the time still to this day
there's functioning junkies out there
who can hold down a [ __ ] nine-to-five
put on a [ __ ] suit and they got a
habit and they got to do a bundle a day
or a half a bundle a day or what's
interesting about those people is I
think most people would be surprised at
how undetectable it is you know there's
a lot of really like you know
functioning heroin addicts or whatever
and you can't necessarily tell I can
tell there's you have this image from
television or whatever that you know
it's a like a dude who weighs a hundred
pounds
you know I mean there's dudes that a
[ __ ] poppin [ __ ] oxys and all
kinds of [ __ ] and it's like unless you
really know and I've been around like I
said since I'm 13 years old and I'm
[ __ ] 58 this year so that's a lot of
years in the [ __ ] trenches of the
drugs and I can pretty much tell but I
always said dude if you guys if these
junkies allocated that amount of time
they could be running [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] 500 fortune 500 companies I'm
like holy [ __ ] the creative [ __ ] that
they had to do reckon the resilience and
the scams and the schemes and I mean I
was there doing it myself but I'm like I
just it's not replayed it's it's it's
redirecting your energy at more than it
is replacing one the addiction for
another and the thing is when I
redirected all that energy I was wasting
and getting high and all the other
[ __ ] the negative [ __ ] my life
started taking a very positive turn and
I was thus able to tell other people
going through it like yo here's what you
got to do replace all that energy put
the energy here you know go go [ __ ] do
this you know and similarly this is a
conversation that dates back to the
first day that I met Mishka shortly
after the long run came out the amount
of energy that that Mishka puts into
resisting like a spiritual program we'll
just call it that if I stop resisting
what are we gonna happen to be on the
[ __ ] jajan the world that would open up
to Mishka if he would avail himself of
the you know the higher powers that be
look well look at it this way you know
like the you know you're familiar with
the you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make a drink with that dynamic
right now there are you know and there
are like you know and they're also
they're like you know there are dogs
that like just want to sit on the couch
and smaller farts all day and then
they're dogs that want to run and like
JJ is a dog that wants to [ __ ] run
you know like give him so much farts to
give him something to pull against and
he'll pull against it you know the you
know but like what I I'm gonna go into
it with this I'm gonna say thank you to
both of you guys cuz like I was thinking
on the way over here I was thinking you
know thinking about the PMA [ __ ] again
it's one of those things when we were
kids we used to mock that [ __ ] and you
were right and we were wrong you know
and like I need to get more of that in
my life I brought a copy of the book for
you you gotta get right but your book
the long run holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] if you
haven't read it you know and you're
dealing with [ __ ] go get that [ __ ]
book right and just so people that are
that are listening if they're newer to
the program and don't know the history
here like we go way back like we were I
met you early days of the podcast you
had written this kindle single the long
run that was like the number one
best-selling I think it probably to this
day is the biggest selling Kindle single
out early write with the Nike shoe worn
out yeah cover that thing still sells
like crazy and [ __ ] legs together so
it's like a little you know it's a it's
it's longer than a short story but
shorter than a typical book yeah kind of
tells the story of how you got sober and
discovered running and became this ultra
and let's not forget finding ultra oh
yeah you know I read it out on the road
when I'm in the van I told you man I'm
like holy [ __ ] I just reread your book
Diane I love the story about how you
guys met where JJ cornered you were in
like who is this vividly now like we
were at we were at the seaside mall in
New York and like chased me down a
hallway or something oh that's that
[ __ ] rich wall guy yo bring me over
there man I don't remember getting
emails from you though that way
it wasn't never emails it was on social
media so I was sending you messages on
Instagram or whatever the [ __ ] and you
never wrote me back
I don't like you and then I said the
Brendan cuz he knew your eyes and Cal
introduced me and I was like yo
[ __ ] would you not get in my but
like is this is one of the ways in which
I will defend my path is that my
existence proves that you can change
your life without swallowing the god
pill if that's so objectionable to you
having been sober for ten years I'm far
more open to spirituality and PMA and
like you know that [ __ ] that I that I
ever was before but you know that's you
know that's where the issues that you
know I had with like veganism is that
it's it's very like Catholic it's either
you're like okay it's either you're
righteous you know and like no you know
no animal anything will ever pass your
lips or you're an outcast you know and
obviously that's you know drug there's a
lot you know traumatized but that's
traumatic and there's also a lot of
projection in that to you right
certainly but people say but do circle
do say that right and that's how a lot
of people perceive it and that's that's
one of the things that I think prevented
me from getting sober for a long time
was that like it's not just that you
need to stop the only thing in this
world that you're good at which is
[ __ ] drinking high life and sitting
on a barstool for 12 to 14 hours but
also you have to believe in God which is
something you've never had and you've
never needed mmm you know well but that
that's not that's not completely
accurate
I mean basically the you know and in in
12-step we got to be a little bit
careful here because I don't want to
like run too afoul of the of the
traditions but the only requirement is
to have a desire to stop drinking and in
terms of of God it's just it's just a
belief in a higher power and what I
always say to people that have issues
around God or have a lot of baggage
around the church or etcetera or
whatever you know that's and I would put
most people in that category
is that it's a higher power of your
design it doesn't have to be the god
that you grew up with or whatever notion
of God you know it's problematic for you
a higher power just means a Power
greater than yourself that could be a
collective a group of people you know in
a room who've all stayed sober longer
than you and have some wisdom around how
to do that that you can summon enough
humility to kind of you know have the
willingness to do what they say as
opposed to whatever you want to do rich
I love you to death and I believe in
higher power but if it's higher power
and not God why does it save God so many
times in the [ __ ] well there's
there's a lot of colloquialisms in the
book too you have to also understand
there was written in a certain time so
there's a lot of things that's the thing
as three hires written in but God was
God and it's a book all right I gotta
slow down here but it's a it's a book
for straight white men who believe in a
Catholic or a Protestant a Christian God
you know how to use higher power I hear
what you're saying I your scan I'm not
against a a but I do think it needs to
evolve and I think that's something
you're arguing in favor of as well I
don't know that I'm I'm not listen you
know I got I got sober in a it keeps me
sober
it's an incredible community and you
know it's you know and my participation
in that community is the number one
priority in my life so you know I'm a
champion of it and I'm always constantly
saying like people need to set aside
whatever preconceived ideas they have
about what it is and what it isn't and
just you know show up and with an open
mind and listen and I've seen incredible
miracles happen there but in terms of my
open mindedness I'm not gonna be the
person who says it's the only way to get
sober I mean both of you guys are
examples of people who've gotten sober
you know via different modalities or in
ways of your own choosing so you know
that being said like I'm certainly not
going to be dismissive of 12-step either
you know like I think it's I think it's
one I think it's a it's a miracle of our
time that not only has it persisted over
the years but it continues to grow and
flourish and hasn't sort of
you know self-destructed because human
beings are behind it
the most [ __ ] up you know human beings
you can possibly imagine I mean just
think about this for a minute you're
gonna get together all these insane
alcoholics and addicts who are all
completely [ __ ] out of their minds it
sounds awesome party until explain to me
how this organization didn't just
completely implode within 30 days of its
being constructed
you know shear forces own well it's a
it's an incredible thing
yeah and it's helped you know thousands
and thousands of people and like look a
lot of people relapse and die like I
know a guy who I just found out the
other day who I knew quite well relapsed
and died I mean that is just part and
parcel of you know being an addict and
an alcoholic I mean this is real-life
[ __ ] the consequences I'm not anti AAA
and I hope that I've never presented you
know misrepresent you know the I just
we're always in well no but I just um I
just praise up or other methods of
getting there that's all I just think
that there needs to be more different
you know for every I mean and look at it
so a is this miracle that happened can't
we conceptualize in our mind eight or
nine or ten or twenty other similar
miracles like a a happening that still
help people get to sobriety and to the
life that we've found the only thing I
would say to that is that when I get
contacted and I do every single day from
people who are out there who are
struggling who you know can't can't get
sober I don't I'm not going to be the
person to say to that person oh well you
can do it your own way I'm gonna be like
here's what you do and I give them very
concrete direct actions that they can
take that have in my experience you know
proven to work when they're done you
know with when they're done properly as
opposed to like well there's lots of
ways like you go figure it out like you
know that's I can't I can't say that to
that person I I smile because one of my
writing students like you know what he
wants me to explain oh how do I get from
here to here and I'm like well [ __ ]
figure it out dude you
to be able to know how to do this I can
tell you how it's done but as a writer
you need to be able to solve these
problems every time I say figure it out
he like threatens my life I have a
friend that uh he's very involved in in
ayahuasca community and and you know he
recently told me something because you
know I kind of slagged it that whole
hallucinogenic thing in my book and you
know at first just the ego I'm like what
are you talking about man it's [ __ ]
drugs and then I'm like wait a minute
you know this guy's helping people that
have been stone-cold straight up you
know Jonathan Shaw the famous tattoo
artists and everything and he's a really
good friend of mine I knew I you know
was he the one who did that book yeah
yeah he's done a bunch of books John
Johnny Depp put out his book but he goes
hey man you know like I just want to
tell you I have a ton of respect for
everything you know you did and we sat
down we were at juice press in New York
he goes but listen man you know you
shouldn't be dissing this this is a this
is a ceremony this is like you know some
magical stuff that's going on and I've
helped people that have been stone cold
[ __ ] junkies for 20 [ __ ] years and
nothing worked for them na they got sick
of going to the rooms it just all of
that stuff and then we go down and we do
these hi Oh Oscar ceremonies under you
know a master that knows how to do the
whole thing and he's like dude they
would they just [ __ ] gave up the
drugs and I'm like you know what I said
you know what bro you're right and and I
won't it's not for me but I'm not gonna
diss something that's helping a lot of
[ __ ] people and they were able to
clean up and get off drugs through that
particular modality yeah I mean one of
the kind of core sayings in
coveri is like you know don't don't
succumb to contempt prior to
investigation that's what he told me he
goes on he gave me that [ __ ] quote he
he gate he told me that and I was like
yo you [ __ ] and I say that yet I say
that to people who have a lot of baggage
around God right or AAA or they just
they have this they have this concept or
this image that was formed through a
television show or whatever about what
it is and I just say you know don't
don't succumb to contempt prior to
investigation go check it out
and and I too have voiced opinions about
ayahuasca in the past but I've never
done it so in many ways that's contempt
prior to investigation and I to know of
people whose lives have been improved as
a result of that experience but also
like you it's not for me like I'm not
gonna take a such a powerful
mind-altering substance into my body at
this point when my evolution like I
don't think it would be wise and I don't
feel like I need it but I also can't
discount the truth that certain people
have been impacted positively as a
result of that and I know that like
people like gob or mati take addicts
through this experience and have had
positive results but I also know people
who then I wouldn't call it a dependence
or an addiction but continue to go back
to those experiences that I'm in time
again it's like I don't know anyone
who's walking around enlightened because
of ayahuasca like we kind of you know go
back to our set point maybe that set
point moves a little bit for certain
people but if I see a guy who's doing it
every weekend or doing it every month
that's into that and yeah there are we
you and I know people oh I know they're
mean so that's where I start to think
well if this is so effective then why do
you have to keep right they'll call it
the work and like and again I don't have
any experience with it so I'm not saying
this with judgment this is pure
observation whenever you guys change
your mind and you want to do it let me
know
you're gonna feel like what you felt
like last night or maybe how you feel
right now
the UH the one of the things I just
before I forget uh in discussions of a
and my resistance to a you know the you
know John you know pulled up a perfect
example of this and I do have resistance
a and our problems with the structure of
it and at every point when I'm being
critical of a a I always feel like I
have to move very carefully and very
delicately because fortunately I have
people like you in my life who have
benefited from so much wisdom from the
rooms [ __ ] that I hear in my day-to-day
life that resonates with me hardcore and
come to find out later that it's it's
you know it's an all day a truism or
it's from directly out of the big book
or whatever so you know I mean I hope
you don't think that I'm coming out you
know [ __ ] knives and guns and all
that [ __ ] you know but because I know
that I you know second or third hand my
life has been enriched by the wisdom of
people in the rooms right so I hope you
know that when I'm am critical about
specific things it's it is in a the most
sort of like loving respectful way
possible because I know right that I
benefited it's still so funny to me to
though because like you said all right
set aside the god part of it right
you're like I have problems with the
structure like for me it's like all
right a group of people who kind of
share a certain kind of problem get
together and they they talk about it
they share their experience their
strengths their hope from a perspective
of trying to be of service to each other
a support system and then there are
these tools like hey if you do these
like things like kind of take inventory
of like how you've lived your life and
you you know you you mend these bridges
with the people that you've heart like
these are all you know ancient
traditions that transcend a book and a
room and a program and a group of people
that you know if you detach from the
labeling around it would just be like
kind of smart common-sense things to do
to kind of in you know improve yourself
and your life experience yeah I have
that group around the world in the life
and it's awesome they're like everywhere
I go and a lot more like fans of yours
you know so I don't know how you go yeah
these
night after night that like that would
wear on my soul I just remember how I
feel right now Apple drinking all the
time I just remember this [ __ ]
feeling I mean for me to like one of the
things I always said was growing up
music how important it was in my life
you know my father was breaking in
raping my mother and beating her and it
was always the music that you know to
address what you're doing cuz you're
getting something out of it that's what
keeps you going for five months on the
road and when I was in the foster homes
it was always music when I was on the
streets it was music when I was locked
up it was music and then I got the gift
from HR who took the mic and said yo get
out there in 81 to play music and I
always would get in the worst places in
my life when I walked away from the
music it's it's part of the whole
process for me to of staying sober is
having those shared experiences with
people in a room he doesn't have to be
in a room doing the 12-step program a
room to me is like we're playing for all
these people and then you have these
amazing conversations afterwards and
it's not involved it's not revolving
around you know we're [ __ ] smoking
weed and having [ __ ] drinks and doing
all this [ __ ] it was always like we're
having these like [ __ ] philosophical
discussions and what's interesting is I
won't mention the person's name but even
the walking tours some dude hit me up
and was like got out of prison and he's
no [ __ ] joke he's a [ __ ] big
[ __ ] strong tattooed [ __ ] maniac
has kids got out of prison and was like
I [ __ ] had a gun and I was gonna
[ __ ] in my life because I went back
to addiction and I started listening to
the podcast rich roll and listening to
the message and got your books and all
this stuff and like and I was like but
at first he was like you know I'm gonna
write John on [ __ ]
- gram let me write this dude and I just
happen to be [ __ ] looking at my phone
and he's sitting there with a [ __ ]
gun and he was like if I don't hear if I
don't get this talk to somebody now I'm
gonna [ __ ] end it and it was I was
like holy [ __ ] and he came out on the
walking tour so what'd you say to him I
see you just yeah I just talked I just
kept telling him about the positivity
man don't isolate don't do this you
listen you gotta get past it the [ __ ]
check out my book do this do that go on
these podcasts listen to this [ __ ] like
we all been there like he didn't say the
words never came to me that I had a gun
and I'm sitting there it was always like
he just kept it he was asking me
questions I found out later because he
came on again on the tour then he told
you [ __ ] you know waited till everybody
else left and he was like dude I just
want you to know like that day I was
gonna end my life and like the fact that
you responded to me and that's the power
to of you know the social media and the
meeting of people in the rooms and minoo
and the gigs and the concerts it's like
I think there's so much good that can
come out of that to like this so it's a
platform you know to to really do a lot
of good [ __ ] and I find like when I step
away from the music and it's kind of
like part of the whole thing for me is
to be doing this and using these
platforms yeah it's your relationship to
the platform you use it it's like a mess
lately because like you know yeah you're
[ __ ] you're getting people hitting you
up to like [ __ ] and it's like doesn't
necessarily have to be we walk into the
basement of a [ __ ] church but it's
there nonetheless it's the room is where
you create it you know yeah I get that I
mean I threw out a tweet thread on New
Year's when I was in Australia basically
saying like you know it's always a gift
on New Year's Day to wake up sober
that's when you really like me so
they're like yeah there was a bunch of
stuff about like because a lot of people
are gonna wake up on New Year's Day
feeling like [ __ ]
you're thinking like it's day one and
I'm not off to a good start and maybe
it's time to reevaluate so every year I
kind of throw something out like that
and I just ended the thread by saying
you know my DMS are always open to
anybody who's you know in that state
right now and wants to talk and I just
got tons of messages and made sure that
I responded to all of those and like
that's that's the service and that's
what it's about and that you could you
know there's a lot of problems with
social media and you know on a macro
level what it's doing a culture and
society but if you can use it for that
purpose you know and like today I'll
ever differ to be of service it's an
incredible tool today I read your post
about the Australian fires because you
were there watching it firsthand and
it's just I mean it brings [ __ ] tears
when I'm seeing what's happening to
these animals and and you posted some
charity links which I'm going to be
donating to and the money goes right to
the organisation's and it's just like we
have to as a [ __ ] humanity needs to
start making a global shift away from
what the [ __ ] we're doing in the path
we're taking in this you know so many
signs of it I just saw another
documentary about Venice that the sea
levels rising the place is going on -
[ __ ] the other and they're losing
these museums in history and they're
freaking the [ __ ] out and just
everything that's going on and I made a
post yesterday and it was like you know
it's somebody saying what if we create
what if it's a hoax and we created a
better world for nothing like oh yeah
it's like [ __ ] come on man like dude
what a waste of time and I you know I I
just saw your posting and cuz you were
over there now it was a vacation and you
affected by the fires well where were
you I was in Sydney for most of the time
and Sydney is not under imminent threat
from the city burning down I think you
know I could be wrong but I believe that
the closest bush fires are something
like 50 kilometers away so it's not
as if you can see the fires from the
city but when the winds blowing a
certain way as it does on most days the
the air was you know the air quality was
unbelievably poor and there were
definitely days where you know I'd go
outside and think this is not a good
idea and you'd walk around and people I
got they have masks on the skies orange
you know walking around the Opera House
couldn't see across yeah you couldn't
see across the harbour the bridge was
obscured because of the smoke it was bad
you know really bad so I didn't see the
fires firsthand and what's interesting
is how you normalized what's happening
because I was there for you know this is
these fires have been going on for four
months right yes I was there well after
they had begun and it's gotten worse
since I left and I know I've been
talking to friends there the air quality
is even worse than it was when I was
there but everyone's you know it's not
like life stops people are going to work
and going about their day because what
else are you going to do and even being
there it's hard to grasp the scope and
the size and the sheer devastation and
the impact of what's happening there I
mean it would be as if you saw those
maps of Australia superimposed over the
United States it's like it would be as
if you know fires are burning from Miami
to Portland Maine you know like it's and
then up around across the Chicago or
something like that you know it's
unbelievable so you know what do we do
like it's in that first post that I made
about that I mean I think that the
impulse is to feel powerless and that
the world is out of control and there's
a kind of desperation or a you know sort
of a hopelessness that comes with you
know acknowledging that level of
dystopia but you know the truth is there
are things that that we can do there are
these relief organizations where we can
be immediately of need to the people who
need that and then there are ways of
dealing with and addressing the macro
problems that are you know shifting the
tectonic plates that lead to these sorts
of things and they're less sexy and and
they don't necessarily need change at
the highest level and it's important to
you know let our governments know what's
acceptable and what is
but there are changes that we can make
right now in our homes and in our daily
habits that don't seem like they're
connected to this problem but ultimately
are and if we want to solve these
problems we do need to take
responsibility for those choices and how
we're living our lives on a daily basis
I mean there's I just saw a huge
disconnect like all the Amazon that's
being cleared and burned to graze cattle
and grow crops to feed the cattle and
it's like the Amazon of the lungs of the
[ __ ] planet and it's like nobody
really said anything about that or and
and then like these fires dwarf out here
sighs yeah but not that they're enormous
the rainforests all over the planet
they're doing that everywhere now like
my friend said to me like how come
nobody talked about what's going on in
Indonesia and all that what they're
doing over there and I think it's that's
what about ISM them yeah any time you
you sort of shine a light on something
then says well what about that you're
talking about this but nobody you know
it's like that's not productive right
you know or so or if you say hey there's
a problem here let's look at it then
then if you or somebody attacks you
because you flew on an airplane it's
like yeah I flew on an airplane like I'm
not I don't you know I don't live as
zero carbon emissions life right I've
never said that I do there are certain
things that I do I have habits around
that hopefully are part of the solution
but I'm not perfect and right now like I
say this all the time like I have an
iPhone where did the where do these
minerals in this phone come from like
you know I'm complicit and whatever that
system is that creates that that
probably is creating a lot more harm
than good so it's it's not about
Puritanism but I think it's about
raising collective consciousness and
awareness oh absolutely
Mich the I want to steer this back to
what to a something we talk we always
talk about the the service thing you
know the because when you're confronted
with all these huge problems it's like
well what like what can I do how can I
help you know the end and also like that
you know the attacks you get from people
like oh you have an iPhone you flew on a
plane all that [ __ ] I think that's one
of the reasons why I struggled with the
idea of service initially is because I
feel like if you're a sober alcoholic or
you know drug addict and you come out of
either you come out of rehab or you come
out of a program or you come out of
[ __ ] white knuckling it in your room
and then people are like oh you now need
to be a better human being than
everybody else
you know I to me it just felt like I
don't know that not that like not that
sober addicts and alcoholics should get
a break necessarily but they shouldn't
have you know they shouldn't have like
this service thing should apply to
everybody or nobody so what are you
saying specifically I mean certainly
well it's not about like it goes back to
not being about Puritanism like as they
say we are not Saints it's about
spiritual you know progress not
spiritual perfection and the truth is if
you've cobbled together a few days of
sobriety then you have a kernel of
experience that would be beneficial to
somebody who can't get one day you know
and for the amount of time that you've
remained sober to somebody who's in that
position you're like a god like how
would you know how is that even possible
that that guy could do that and and that
you know so detaching that from whatever
other decisions you're making in your
life that that you know make you an
angel or a devil like let go of all of
that and just focus on the fact that
you've been able to string together some
time without drinking or using drugs and
and how can you communicate a message to
that person who's in that vicious cycle
who feels like they could never escape
it so that they can hit the pillow that
night just one night without without
getting loaded yeah I mean I think you
know part of this goes back to the oh
you're replacing one addiction with
another that kind of [ __ ] too you know
where I feel like you know sober
alcoholics and addicts are like
subjected to all this [ __ ] from
people who like feel like it's their
business to to weigh in on our lives and
the decisions that we're making and like
oh is that healthy for
you to be running the amount that you
are in that kind of [ __ ] and somebody
asked me point-blank you know like what
do you think you are debt is to two
other people you know trying to get
sober and I said nothing I owe them
nothing I'm if I help people it's gonna
be because I want to and not because I
have some [ __ ] obligation it's not
like you need to do your homework or you
need to clean your room no I I mean and
that's the thing about my sobriety is
like I got sober on my own I didn't lean
on anybody else you know and so like I'm
happy to have written what I've written
and I'm happy to help people where I can
but I hate this idea of I'm down was I'm
coming around I came around on PMA I
came around on plant-based I'm coming
around on service but I it's just the I
guess it's the mode of entry of you know
that like newly sober addicts are
compelled to do this you know rather
than here's an opportunity for you to
you're looking at me are you gon go
forth first of all I would call into
question that you got sober on your own
I know you want to believe that and I
think that that's on some level a
delusion I think that you got sober
because you're surrounded by people that
love you and they may not have been you
know rapping your knuckles and telling
you what to do specifically but don't
discount the impact that you know your
family members and your friends may have
had on your sober story that's one thing
and I think that 9/10 yeah go how your
addiction you just spent time with your
old man right well that's a whole I know
it crossed your mind at some point what
your so what your addictions were doing
to the other people that yeah right the
connection yeah that's that's what you
know we keep talking about with music
with performing was right it all comes
back to connection right you know and
and and that connection is fundamental
to
you getting sober and staying sober
right the family you have connection to
other human beings and there are
absolutely been times when I've been in
those [ __ ] dank wet bars when I think
of the two of you and that's you know
what part of the barricade right so so
you know my voice is in your head on
some level or JJ's is in your head when
you're in a situation that you know is
somewhat precarious yeah right
so how much are you doing this alone so
there's that the second thing is we can
move along the second thing IRA but your
rebuttal I think there is a spiritual
truism that if you want to keep
something you have to give it away right
like if you want to be loved you have to
give love if you want to stay sober you
have to be of service to other people
who are struggling in sobriety if you
whatever it is that you and if you hold
on too tightly to a certain thing that's
a sure path to losing it so I think that
is baked into this idea of what service
is it's not like hey go be a good boy
scout and you must you know you are
compelled to be of service but there is
a priority or a or you know a lot of
energy behind kind of getting people
energized around that because that's
what keeps people sober so I know that
if I'm on the phone on the daily with
somebody who's in and out and who is
struggling that that makes me work my
program more strongly because you can't
give away something you haven't got
and I'm duplicitous if I'm telling that
person to do one thing and I'm not
practicing it myself so it keeps me
honest
so the giving it away really I get I get
more out of that than that person that
person may you know never get sober
but it's like an insurance policy for
myself that I know that whatever that
guy or woman or whoever whatever that
person does like I'm pretty sure that my
head will hit that pillow sober tonight
yeah I listen I totally agree it and I
mean that's what I said you know what
I'm coming around to the idea of service
cuz like you know when the rare
instances where I've done something to
help another person I always feel good I
know that you and I know yeah I know cuz
we've talked about this too and it get
it I think it really puts life
into you and I see you doing it on
social media and I think there's a
sustenance to that that may be because
you're so recalcitrant you're refusing
to just embrace you know I get you cuz I
know you but somebody else look at it
would be like yeah the but do you see
the point that I'm making though I do
that I I feel like we put a lot of
pressure on people who are newly sober
to be too good to give back too much too
fast and I don't think that's
necessarily true though I think that's
that that's the projection on some level
also and what I see and I'll let you
finish in a second but my question to
you is you you hold on so tightly to
this ideology or this perspective and my
question to you is what would happen if
you just let go of all that oh [ __ ] here
comes the next challenge right yeah the
now I just feel like you and JJ found a
way to poison me in Mexico come in here
we can sleep I don't fall over
go ahead the but but you see my point
though about the oh you're replacing one
addiction with another that kind of [ __ ]
like that's not helpful and and I think
you know the three of us and lots of
other people like you know survive have
survived bad advice or bad input or
useless information from people like
that early on and that and it's it's
stuff that doesn't propel you forward
and if anything it's it's stuff that
pushes you back and it makes you think
like oh well [ __ ] this I should just go
have a drink and not put up with this
horseshit I get you but I think a cantor
point to that is that we're not always
the most objective when it comes to our
decision-making right and you know I
think any rational person would say like
if you have a big decision to make
or
you're acting in a certain way like run
that by people that you trust and
respect and get their feedback on that
that's what my mom lives four houses
down like you know thinking that I'm on
this great path and it will take another
person who knows me well that I'm very
connected with to say hey man like I see
you you know doing this thing over here
like do you ever think like maybe you
know bump up a BA and I'll be like wow I
never would have thought that or you
know maybe I disagree but you've been
right about so many other things like I
need to rethink that you know so I think
it's just being a sounding board and you
know I need somebody to reflect back my
own behavior because I'm not so good at
taking on a stock of it because my ego
gets involved and all my character
defects cloud my perspective so that I
don't see it clearly I I mean I agree
with a lot of what you're saying you
don't mean I think and I think that you
know and we've talked about this before
that like it probably would have
benefitted me early on and now to lean
on people more than I do you know that
like you know last night when I was like
lying there thinking I was gonna die I
was like well there's a good it's a good
thing there's nobody around because then
I would cry to them and instead of just
laying there [ __ ] by myself you know
the I couldn't get the dog to come over
and like cuddle me the and I you know
and I don't have any fantasy that like I
exist in a vacuum and I tried to and not
stupid and that's why I understand how
stupid it is and you know and we've
talked so much on you know on this
podcast about connection and and the
power of behind that of I mean that's
the only way that I know to make sense
of all this [ __ ] that we deal with on
this earth is the connection between
people you know loving one another
communicating with people you know so I
absolutely believe in all of that I'm
just you know I I just the I just think
that we put too much on newly sober
people when the I think I think people
need to choose service that's what
that's what one of my favorite things
about you dude is that when [ __ ] JJ
was busting my balls about the garbage
that I used to eat you were always like
nah it's fine he can he can just eat
whatever you know and I said
I know you said that guy said that oh
you see I mean you were you were like
you know just you know try it for a
month or try eating more plants or
whatever you know and now it's been
whatever two and a half years since I've
eaten meat and I'm not going back and
but also like you know JJ was like I was
too in gum one time and you were like
here aspartame you're like spit that
[ __ ] out and I did you know cuz when JJ
tells you do something you do it
but having the two of you having the
good angel and the devil one on each
shoulder that have that multiplicity
that that was incredibly helpful to me
and that's helped me move forward and
that's for the same reason why I
advocate for more more ways of getting
sober you know is when you have more
options like that you know that you know
it's like if you know to go back to the
old tired analogy you know you could
lead a horse to water but you can't make
him drink you know it's like it when my
cat doesn't want to eat you know I could
like shove her head in the ball she
won't eat but if I like rattle a little
bit of food in my hand and then sort of
sneak it away from her she's like yo
what's in your hand
you know then she'll she wants to say oh
what is that and then when she feels
like she's getting something from me
though she'll eat you know I can't eat
it right out of the bowl and put it in
my hand it's just presentation I got you
I think we could go in circles on this
for a long time and I don't know how
productive that is but I have to say
maybe one final thing and then we could
talk about some other stuff and that is
that you cannot solve a problem with the
same mentality that created it and if
you're [ __ ] up on drugs and alcohol
and you're making decisions in a certain
way if you think that you're going to
solve that problem with that same brain
that is making those decisions and
you're you're lost like it's it's not
gonna work right like you've got to get
a different perspective and I don't
think I would take issue with this this
supposition that that that 12-step puts
too much pressure on newly sober people
to be of service that I got I wasn't
you're gonna swipe a 12-step with that
or just now I think it's just the the
community-at-large
you know that like people who are I mean
when you're when you're newly sober it's
all about like helping that person get
sober and like tea everything else
tabled until later until they've you
know cannot my experience do you I've
had people who I didn't even know
there's a lot of programs that ain't the
best right I got you like Michael let's
take for instance Michael Lago right who
signed Metallica as the film who the
[ __ ] is that guy here's a person who's
worked Cyndi Lauper's Nina Simone you
want to talk about who's who in the
music business and he's never talks
about it but every single morning no
matter what he's doing he goes in and he
sets up the [ __ ] chairs he sets up
the room he gets to coffee and the way
I've seen him and the compassion and
understanding and love and patience that
he gives to newly sober people it's it's
it's incredible and that is I think what
has the most effect and the time that he
gives up himself
to call these people and follow-up never
like being heavy handed I don't think if
somebody was heavy-handed with me when I
was coming off crack I would have
[ __ ] knock him the [ __ ] out to tell
you the truth it was people with a lot
of compassion that were like hey man
like you know this is what you know this
is what are you doing oh yeah like just
going on some somebody compassion
they're like I really felt like they
were truly honestly concerned for my
well-being and I think there's a lot of
people that are in in the 12-step
program and na and AAA that do that same
thing and have helped a ton of people
you know and Michael Lago is a great
example of it and he doesn't brag about
what he does he doesn't put anybody's
dirt out there it's just he's doing it
it's selfless service he's not getting
anything out of it because he doesn't
even talk about it but what you were
saying it helps his own sobriety hundred
percent hundred and I find it for myself
too it's when I'm talking to people I'm
constantly
reminding myself of those same facts of
those experiences of of what it was like
I can empathize with this person
suffering and be like holy [ __ ] I was
[ __ ] there man I know with that
person's feeling like and also it helps
you revisit that and connect with that
so that you don't go back absolutely
yeah the [ __ ] the the best shows that
I've had in this last year are we
started doing shows up my house in
Phoenix and just and I cuz like I know
how [ __ ] hard it is to get a gig and
a gig that pays when you're on the road
so we've just been doing house shows for
people when they come through and like I
usually don't even play
I usually just I host I we have a door
that we took off like one of the see
your version of Bisbee like Doug's yeah
the stage is just a door you laugh next
time you're in town you're gonna die
there that's those are the best [ __ ]
shows man and goes like the best nights
of my life
you know like but the happiest man oh my
that's where you filled nose connected
my friend Kristen Becker came through
she's telling jokes about [ __ ]
prolapses my mom is sitting like right
in front of her like laughing her ass
off but I was like this is what this is
how we make sense of like the [ __ ]
carnage of humanity is to just talk
about everything together you know and
to like to have all these people you
might die my my my BFF Robin and her
girlfriend let men then Sam and his
buddy on their Harley's there's we got
the bikers and the lesbians and I was
like oh oh and I walked over there and
are like they're both just talking [ __ ]
about me we're good
but so I get it man you know it's like
those I live for those shows man they've
been [ __ ] awesome we're gonna we're
trying to do them every month now it's
cool good deal man
so tell me about the new book that's
coming out the genius man could be your
life Oh God John reach there's there's
mishka's book see at the bottom of that
right there
I gotta get a screencap see this is
always my thing with you two I'm so glad
you've got these two pieces coming out
because I really think I love your
writing man I really do
so it's what I do best I got to get back
to it I've been [ __ ] you know I love
the road and it totally energizes me and
like it's time for the pendulum you
gotta move in order to have stories to
tell uh yeah it's been too long those
experiences like material for the next
yeah yeah thing you know the so in 2018
when I did the five months on the road I
broke up with my girlfriend Maddie in
Atlanta because how can you keep a
relationship together when one of the
person you know one of the people was
[ __ ] never there and I broke her
heart and I broke my heart you know the
and then I couldn't even like feel bad
about it cuz I knew that I was my
[ __ ] fault - we talked about that
when I saw you in London
yeah the that was I was so grateful to
see you then dude I can't tell you like
I was just so beat up at that moment the
did you ever feel like you were gonna
drink again [ __ ] yeah dude yeah so the I
blame you and rich for the failure to
relapse but you did it alone I did it
alone with you with you alone with you
there the no so this this piece is about
in 2018 like whatever three months deep
into this I took that that [ __ ] up
1976 Chevy campervan mm-hmm loaded my
sister as my mom and my
my sister's kids into the van we drove
2,000 miles up to Saskatchewan for my
mom for that family reunion my mom comes
from a family of 17 kids and and she had
just lost her brother the year before
the first of the 17 to die
my younger sister to Sheena's birth
father so it was just it was like really
emotional and then like going into it
man I was like already insane by the
time we got into the van it's like okay
now you have to deal with for little
kids driving through the [ __ ] Nevada
desert at 150 degrees with no air
conditioning and like the chunga no
unfortunately he he didn't go the
explain who Chung is Cho meet I swear
I'll make it up to you it's all like
that guys the lead character I can't
tell you how many messages I've gotten
from people who are like bro I'm halfway
through the book I got a note just Chung
ever reappear I'm like [ __ ] boy the
knot Chum still get he's he's in
Albuquerque his son is actually going to
to school in Arizona so I'm gonna try
and reconnect with his son soon but Chun
is my Vietnamese foster brother he was a
refugee from Vietnam came over spent two
years in a refugee camp in Malaysia
about [ __ ] harm and he has seen the
and now he lives in Albuquerque he has a
landscaping business and you guys need
your yard started Albuquerque hit me up
I'll hook you up with Chung yeah but but
yeah he was in and he ran away when I
was a teenager he was gone for 20 years
and then just [ __ ] reappeared one way
bike and now he's he's he's in your life
now though right yeah yeah we you know
we we talk regularly and you know tags
back and forth and stuff yeah so all
right so this this family reunion like
why what made you want to write about
this like what is this about well I just
you know my like my family they're all
like redneck oil people Trump lovers you
know the you know the only only book I
ever read was the Bible and that's good
enough for me you know which I guess
that explains a lot huh Wow I didn't
just just figure that one out on air the
the but I love them all I love him
dearly
you know and
and I would [ __ ] take a bullet for
any woman but that's my family you know
and so I was trying to sort of like
figure out like why you know why is it
so important to me and also like I just
felt like my family was sort of falling
apart my sister had gone through this
[ __ ] rough divorce and you know they
were all on the west coast and I was in
Atlanta and like been in New York most
of my life and I was just feeling really
disconnected but from everybody and then
I was like okay this is it
this van is gonna this is like a time
machine we're all just gonna get into
the scooby-doo Magic Mystery Machine and
we're gonna travel together and that
journey is gonna turn us back into what
we were before you know family and
created an expectation there are a
couple of bumps along the way rich but
we survived you know we survived and
I've learned a lot during that trip one
of the things I learned is learning
hurts and that you know people my family
have an incredible amount of patience
for me and the [ __ ] that I submit
them to but you know but since that it's
been great you know I mean myself like
my older sister Tatiana and I we had
some [ __ ] that was sort of brewing up
between the two of us and we ended up
squashing that on that trip Tichina and
I had sort of not there was not like no
were like bad blood really but we just
sort of fought a touch and then doing
this trip together I was like oh man
like you you really chilled out in the
last 10 years
you know the you're not the kid that I
remember and the you know and then it
ended up perfectly like Tichina and my
mom and I like all live in Phoenix now
with enough distance between us that
were not you know walking on each other
and and one of the things I learned to
you from doing that trip and writing
that piece was that I had to cut my dad
out of my life and that's been really
hard and an incredibly liberating - you
know there's like you you can pump a
certain amount of energy into something
and at a certain point you just have to
say enough s'en of credit you know yeah
it's something was it an accumulation of
thing
did one thing happened that made you I
mean there was a lot of [ __ ] you know
like the you know politics now is like
such you know there's how many divorces
have been caused by Trump's elections
you know like the for a lot of friends
minded they were sort of like [ __ ] who
is this guy that I married you know the
and so that you know there's been that
pressure with my dad but I've been sort
of you know I just skirted I was like
dad you're my dad I'm not gonna talk
about this with you so we're just gonna
fight so let's talk about [ __ ]
classic rock or whatever you know the
and then the he he was invited to my
sister's wedding and and he said he
wasn't gonna come because it was like
dishonest and deceitful or you know
something like that and I was like yo no
offense dad but like you were [ __ ]
your secretary you banded your wife and
your children like [ __ ] get those
words out of your [ __ ] mouth you know
like we took you back like how dare you
step to my sister and [ __ ] she you
know she's got four kids she's working
her ass off you know she she was a good
kid she wasn't the drunk she wasn't the
[ __ ] like how [ __ ] dare you so that
was the line for me he didn't do
anything to me it was my sister but I
was like if I have to pick one I'll pick
her any day man sorry to hear that
you know what it's good it's been good
it's really it's like a weight has
lifted
yeah and how does everyone in your
family feel about the fact that you've
written about them they read it by this
point they tolerate be you know kids
were like how much are we gonna get paid
I was like [ __ ] nothing how did this
come about
you were you were kind of the golden
child of the Kindle singles you know
initiative but that went the way of the
dodo right like they discontinued that
program I don't know why it was cool
well that David Blum the guy who created
it he left he moved on to something else
and then they just sort of ran it into
the ground where there was like just so
much stuff you know the so then this is
sort of a new sort of relaunching of it
it's originals yeah it's basically the
same idea yeah yeah basically and
that'll be out January 21st and then I
an audio book coming out in March we got
to do a [ __ ] audio book together or
something sometimes now what we're doing
right now I guess a live audio book a
radio play but that's that's the cold
turkey one how to quit drinking by not
drinking yeah here is your self-help
manifesto yeah I feel so conflicted
about it do you know I feel so
completely doing doing an edit on this
after the podcast
what are you doing edits on you
[ __ ]
look at this yeah I haven't read it yet
and apologize God think they don't read
it it's like oh no the way that rich is
acting he's already read it from
audiobook you could just take breaks
every 10 minutes or whatever and then
cut to me and I'll like give you my
reaction right there's cut but that's
cool that's like a new you know you know
you you're a master storyteller but the
kind of self-help genre you know this is
a new new like kind of thing for you I
mean I know you've written articles for
the fix and things like that on on your
sober journey but you know what
extrapolation of that I'll be totally
honest I really didn't want to do it I
actively did not want to do it they just
hit me when I was [ __ ] desperate and
I needed money okay I was like okay [ __ ]
I'll do it and then when I got into it I
was like oh [ __ ] I actually really
really care about this a lot and this in
some ways this is like my [ __ ] life's
work right here
so it's similar to the long run I didn't
want to write the long run but David
Blum sat me down he was like nah this is
what you're writing dude yeah so I just
you know the yeah it ended up being you
know tremendously meaningful to me and I
hope that it helps people but that's
gonna be audiobook only yeah yeah
there's a Kindle yeah I'm gonna talk to
bird and see if we can sell it as a
physical book to the but right now it's
it's just audiobook right the and JJ
you're writing it you got a cookbook
yeah just think you got your YouTube
show yeah my youtube channel the hot
truth yeah
it's later did you see his latest videos
like real men eat quiche oh yeah real
men do [ __ ] eat you so there you go
but yeah you know I just do that for fun
I've paid for everything and you know
just have a good time with it try to
have interesting people from time to
time try to get Rodricks cool you know
the first double amputee to finish Kona
was supposed to come on let's crawl and
you know he couldn't make it so trying
to do that coming up and then I finished
a cookbook it's being edited so it's
like over a hundred plant-based recipes
and a lot of the newer information it's
you know out there to help people you
know to lead a healthier more you know
productive so the PMA cookbook not it's
not it doesn't have anything to do it
really mindset too much I mean I what's
the title that I'm waiting for yourself
you know what I did meet ISA pussy's
somebody I posted on it and somebody
[ __ ] took me to [ __ ] calm and all
this [ __ ] and then they wrote me and
they're like yo I'll sell you the
[ __ ] thing I'm like it meet me on
Avenue D cash in my pocket show up like
so I just I don't [ __ ] you know
disgusting we got the 30 to life thing
right how's that is that coming yeah
it's being edited I just talked to Kip
and Paul de Gelder a Anacin who did what
the health in its we're supposed to see
it edit I think in early June or
something the first first edit of it
right I think we talked about this last
time but basically you and Paul de
Gelder did this like limited series
where that's being produced by Kip from
cowspiracy and what the health where you
go to these guys who have a me
foundation right who have just gotten
out of prison long term long like saying
there's like hardcore guys right and you
go
and you like get their diets sorted out
and watching me chill the former all-pro
linebacker did yo there was a lot of
people involved
we had krishna das came and chanted with
them it was like all different people
and and and bringing different gifts to
the table to help you know these guys
because you know the recidivism rate in
California is [ __ ] like over eighty
percent I believe if you do over 10
years the odds of you going back to
prison and then just seeing the
documentary the 13th
about the 13th amendment the what they
did to you know basically legalizing
slavery in the prison system and just
seeing people come out of prison and die
and myself being incarcerated for two
years and how I changed I just took it
to Paul and I was like yo I got this
thing and then me and him baked it and
took it to Kipp and then tip did you
know we it was organic to at that point
you know we figured that we were going
to work with homeboy industries that
didn't happen the producer that he had
knew this place Amity foundation and
these are these [ __ ] went
through [ __ ] gladiator school there
was guys that did [ __ ] 40 years
saying quittin riots Chino you [ __ ]
talk about people that been through [ __ ]
and what got me the first day was one of
the most hardcore
[ __ ] the you ever seen in your
life this guy Hollywood I named him
Hollywood because I was like this guy's
a [ __ ] star and he [ __ ] we sat in a
semi-circle and everybody we all went
around us you know we talked Paul like
they had seen Paul on Shark Week and if
you don't know who he is there's no time
for fear book whatever it's [ __ ]
amazing yeah he's [ __ ] just such a top
act and after we all relate our stories
and Keith went and the other people and
then the guys went around the room this
guy got he just started [ __ ] he just
broke down crying
I had to get up and walk the [ __ ] out of
the room this is a [ __ ] 220 pound
dude who's been fighting for his life
and and he was like sorry and he came
back and he was like I just never had
people care about me you know and he
really felt we weren't trying to exploit
you to get you know something onto
Netflix oh whatever the [ __ ] medium it
ends up coming out to film whatever it
was like he really felt like we were
there to help and you know cuz I had
read this thing in such a magazine and I
talked about it which Sasha means the
mode of goodness and I read this like 25
years ago about this guy that went into
the prison system and taught people to
be plant-based and Buddhist and all this
and this prisoner said if I had this
knowledge that I'm getting now and he
became plant-based and a Buddhist in
prison and he was locked up for double
homicide he's never gettin out and I was
like that's so [ __ ] powerful it never
it never left me the power of the
changes that I've seen in my life
through through doing all this and being
of service to others and like Kip's
people the minute they heard it like we
gave it to Kip on on Wednesday Friday he
had the funding and then we just went in
there it's 30 to life it's called and it
was 30 days and to change it's a double
entendre to because like I think right
30 to life is the last sentence you can
get before double life which means
basically you're probably going to
[ __ ] die in prison so it's like and
meeting these guys that I'm still
friends with them as a matter of fact
the cro-mags played the [ __ ] in the Roxy
and they all [ __ ] came and they were
up in the [ __ ] balcony cro-mags
shirts all these dudes and I just turned
and I got [ __ ] choked up man I was
like looked at these dudes and the place
was packed and I go these [ __ ]
right here this is these are my [ __ ]
family over here and they didn't know
what the [ __ ] I did with the bro mags
they were like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] like and we did everything
that those guys wanted to do if they
wanted to play play guitar or get a job
here or a chef or whatever it was just
amazing people involved and it's not a
few of them that final day when you did
like the 10k down and what was amazing
right the whole community embraced those
guys the running community they were
just like they some of these guys never
ran a [ __ ] quarter-mile right much
less what they did and and the whole
community down there the running
community were [ __ ] waiting for every
one of these guys to cross the front and
funny enough you were like we never ran
together you were saying I know how is
that possible but it's like today with
Michigan though yeah yeah
and then Paul had him jumping out of
planes and keith was teaching him yoga
we took him to an animal sanctuary like
they were learning about service feeding
the homeless and one guy [ __ ] dude he
was sold into slavery as a [ __ ] child
that by his uncle or whatever this guy
John and in the south and like [ __ ]
his whole life spent in prison and he
never met his grandchildren and and the
producers reached out to his family they
cut him off and they're like and I
wasn't in town as I had to keep going
back from the west coast to New York for
other stuff I had going on but like the
producers and kid told me dude the
[ __ ] those kids showed up at that
Airport with signs and balloons the the
world's best grandpa and there's not
gonna be a [ __ ] dry eye because like
you know I wasn't even there and just
the thought of that that they gave him a
chance to read connect with his family
and meet his grandchildren and all this
stuff and he's the most he's the
sweetest person and I always say that
too you don't know how somebody ended
there's a history to how these men and
women ended up in prison it's not cut
and dry it's and you know and even
addiction there's
there's a reason why people will slip
into that so you always have to have
compassion and an understanding and and
that's where to me I'm like this pay it
forward thing really does matter because
people reached out to me when I was a
mess in 1980 in the Navy I just came out
of lockup two years I was [ __ ]
hustling selling drugs beating people up
[ __ ] I was [ __ ] I was an addict and
people reached out and helped me and
when I asked them you know how to [ __ ]
do I pay you back they're like you can't
just pay it forward you know and it's
like that's what I try to do with you
know social media and you know whatever
right but are all your issues with the
Navy sorted out at this point it's done
by my bass player try to get me out of
the way but yeah the paperwork's taken
to the river works good ie thank you
count
I do man believe it or not I still don't
have a license my girls like I'm not
anyway here's the thing you come to LA
and you stay with towel downtown right
now he has a girl so I get to stay with
my rent Airbnb oh you do but you're
downtown yeah and then you're like hey
let's go to dinner I weren't like for
people that don't know it's like a
two-hour drive from where we are yeah
and I know weren't you supposed to who
was I with a Rob Moore was here the
other day yeah she was going out in
Santa Monica and you wanted him to go
like to Crossroads and he's like like
got a driver's license and renovating
cars like coming down here or like uber
I overheard I [ __ ] over here but only
because what's his name she was supposed
to dry so tow the chef who's amazing
from the series from this yeah and you
know what actually he's good just posted
up and and and I gotta give this
[ __ ] props because he's still
working at a MIDI and he's been getting
these guys jobs as chefs in some of the
top restaurants in LA and he just posted
a picture with all these [ __ ] guys
and it's like you know yeah but he had
some meetings and he had
we went late and he slept in whatever
the [ __ ] but he's he's my boy man I met
so many magical people through the
through that through that whole thing
but yeah coming out here it's you know
hey you know before over everyone
avoided me like they'd be like yeah come
out I'm like yo man what's up they're
like you got to drive downtown and pick
you up they don't answer and then and
then I heard through the grapevine yeah
they're like that [ __ ] don't got
a car and he asked if Nawrocki that's he
had to get into the [ __ ] arm yeah
it's like I'll take my bike it's a
classic like rich man poor man thing
like that's what super rich guys do and
guys you don't have two nickels do
anyway what's the next Iron Man oh I got
two this year I'm doing st. George I
just had hernia surgery last year which
[ __ ] me up but I still got Cozumel
done I had I hurt my hernia sir I
injured the surgery on 12 with the
cro-mags I waited a month the doctors
like to cancel you had to cancel a bunch
of dates right I can't so [ __ ] tours
big ones but you know the thing was my
doctor she was like oh yeah you can go
back to training and you know after two
weeks and then she's like hey you could
go and play and then I came back off the
road we had cuz we had to stop in New
York and I went to see her and she's
like I was like yeah I [ __ ] up I think
I'm [ __ ] something up like and she's
like what kind of music do you do and I
sure to the video she's like I would
have [ __ ] never like you [ __ ] get
on stage and do that are you [ __ ]
kidding me she's like she's like cancer
the rest of this tour I said I can't do
that
she goes no singing she cleared me for
Ironman I would sing she I did me 20
miles 10 days after hernia surgery and
[ __ ] JJ does a couple of shows and
[ __ ] right she was she cleared me to
do to Ironman in Cozumel right before
Thanksgiving but she said no more
singing right let me do the Ironman but
no more chrome a shot yeah so like I've
been healing up from that doing a lot of
like I said salt baths and yoga and CBD
oil which I discovered which really
[ __ ] this company
Sanja helps me out they you know it just
really kills the [ __ ] pain and you
know and like that but I got Saint
George coming up May 4th in Utah and
then I got Lake Placid which I've been
on new food for years and it's gonna be
touring with blood clot this year again
and I started doing a lot of speaking
engagements now you thank you by the way
you hooked me up with somebody I was
trying to get in touch with me I'm doing
like this thing in Richmond when I get
home cool through your plan man
Mishka outs of running going you got
back into it good until the last couple
of days man the yeah I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna get back to it this year another
marathon yeah the this is gonna blow
your guy's minds but I feel like since I
stopped eating meat and consuming dairy
I feel like I recover no hear me out bro
no I just been 4,000 the no man I mean
like there I feel like there's no word
that's like more overused or annoying as
you know inspiring or inspiration or
whatever but one of my boys
Travis res comic in Santa or he's in
Austin Texas now he was like oh this is
gonna be the I you know my yearly
rereading of I swear I'll make it up to
you and I pretend that I'm gonna get
back into running and then it's gonna
fail and I was like well let's do 50
miles together this month and he was
like alright [ __ ] it let's do it so we
did it and then we did a hundred miles
the next month
and then I was like oh [ __ ] now we
started training for a marathon you know
beautiful a recovery is good you look
slim dude you have [ __ ] four days of
throwing up that'll do it for you man
the now the I've been here's another
mind blower I've been wearing myself
down to it
blake out there on the road man like
just eating garbage and not exercising
and not sleeping and [ __ ] like that and
that's been a big thing for me is like
i'm really I mean I'm not gonna say I'm
gonna quit but I'm gonna try and like
dial it way back and you know I love my
house I love my cat I love my girlfriend
I love my mom I love my family you know
I love doing these house shows and like
really trying to you know the trying to
build a community in Phoenix that I can
you know really feel like I belong there
and getting getting back to writing you
know I edited Mark lanagin's memoir that
is the [ __ ] darkest thing you've ever
read in my life it's [ __ ] brilliant
but tell me who he is I thought most
most people know him as the singer of
Screaming Trees he's also put out like
15 incredible solo records you know his
book of lyrics was praised by Nick Cave
and Moby and [ __ ] everybody and he's
an incredible I mean he was a heroin
addict like living under a bridge
smoking crack smoking meth you know like
[ __ ] done everything and I tricked
him and talked him into writing a memoir
and then Byrd hooked him up and you know
we got him a deal cool and then we did
this [ __ ] book together and it was I
mean I was like you know he's like one
of my last remaining musical heroes Wow
it's a book out it'll be out in April I
think it's April 24th come bring him in
here man and we'll talk about that if
man if you could get him on the podcast
I've made him laugh well yeah my you're
my you're my hookup the all you go I'll
get everything I can and make it happen
I made a vlog through bird though uh
yeah yeah I made him laugh once in my
life I was telling him the story about
drinking my own piss when I was
shipwrecked making that Stoney gargoyle
laughs once was the most gratifying
thing I've ever done dude it's like he's
a legendary did you correct you co-wrote
are you edit you just know I added it
it's Mark's work you know the IE it was
just sort of nagging him and nudging him
and you know prodding him forward and
you know doing everything I could to
sort of coach him through it or whatever
but it was you know I mean it's really
been the creative experience in my
lifetime to work with one of my heroes
like that and also to be put in the
position of working with one of your
heroes to be like yo this isn't good
enough
you've got to redo that part you know
that's right [ __ ] nerve-wracking I'm
also working on a screenplay um I met a
guy you don't even live in LA I know I
met a guy through mark we were like
hanging out at marks house and I was
like I was [ __ ] on LA and I was like
yeah I have a screenplay idea but I'm
not gonna go around [ __ ] talking to
people at parties about it and he was
like well what's the idea you know
what's the idea and I told him and he
was like that's a great idea
Ridley Scott is doing my next screenplay
let's make this happen
no so what a [ __ ] way and he's
granges enix no no I was out here I was
out here at Wow okay yeah who is this
person his his name is Roberto I'm gonna
say his last name wrong benevento benta
he just sold Gucci the screenplay of the
Gucci family that [ __ ] Lady Gaga I
was gonna play the lead huh holy [ __ ]
yeah so and he's great dude super
talented writer uh-huh very gives me
good direct communication on what's
working so you probably shouldn't tell
us what that's about right the I mean
the the gist of it is you know if you
look at you know classic horror movies
the monster is like technology or like
interracial marriage or marijuana you
know it's always some social anxiety so
in this instance the monster is
addiction hmm yeah I'll send you guys
the you know the I oh wow that's
exciting yeah yeah I'm psyched you know
so that's that's the thing this year is
all about like [ __ ] hunkering down
you know getting back to running maybe
I'll come out to st. George drive out
and you know and hang out with you ronk
you thought you're gonna be hanging out
that much running and writing dude
running writing and getting my health
you know [ __ ] back to where it needs
to be yeah
and building community connection rich
you should try it no don't try to do
this alone Michigan
man right dude yeah I love you I love
you too man it's probably like no I'm
gonna be back in in March for a couple
weeks okay say no I'm in ten food that's
wrong no yeah a lot of great places in
New York now glad organic grill and you
know percent that's my reach age feels
guilty if we don't go to black yeah well
here's my thing rushing like formal
martial art is you know open is I'm a
crazy bit organics by and my routine is
when I go to New York I always take the
first flight out it's usually like the
7:00 a.m. or 6 a.m. out of LA so it gets
me to New York Atlanta I land at JFK
like 3:30 or whatever
uber into the city get checked into my
hotel and then just and then walk to
meet JJ for dinner like that's a
tradition yeah like I'm here and usually
we go to organic grill because of our
boy flag yeah and the great food but the
last time we went somewhere else and I
did I was like I felt so guilty I was
like I know it was packed and you know
sometimes I can't get a table in them
like I [ __ ] created a monster
I promoted the [ __ ] out of this place
now I can't even [ __ ] get in there
but I'll he's like hey I haven't she I
just loved the way he says you know my
friend John he wrote the book meters for
[ __ ] like he's a great guy no [ __ ]
so cool I convinced him to get the
restaurant to go plan pace get rid of
the fish to Dairy 2 and he was nervous
at first I said dude your place is gonna
blow the [ __ ] up mmm yeah we felt guilty
we were like every bite we were like no
we ate around the corner but we gotta
get us come to Phoenix - you gotta come
and do an event that's races on my
[ __ ] radar cuz I'm racing with ye Inc
the hit squad and Heather Jackson won
that race before and thought I think she
trains Dyer man she trains down there to
write with you know she cycles down
there there's there's
at the end whenever you guys are in
tonight the end yeah you really are
trying to create your own Bisbee aren't
you I'm trying to I'm trying to [ __ ]
build my tribe right do you have any
like pickup trucks on cinder blocks in
the yard stuff like that yeah you I
figured out this my whole life like I
lived in New York like 17 years I'll
never forget you know into your
apartment and Brooklyn the first time I
met you imagine that but in a [ __ ]
yard in a house it's like I can't
believe this guy lives here man I forgot
that one tree boy then I was I was in
Greenpoint
oh right I'm overlooking two BQE point I
got some history in there but yeah that
it wasn't the neighborhood it was the
apartment proper yeah the way it was set
up that was the cleanest that's ever
been your roommate and like it was just
a weird situation between chill on the
floor and an alliance was formed all
right we got to land this plane but
let's let's close it down with you know
if you had to like pick a predominant
theme of this conversation is sobriety
right so for the person who's in that
cycle who feels stuck or doesn't feel
like maybe they need to get sober or you
know just hasn't really found the
lifeline and something that you guys
said today you know connected with that
person or spoke to them like let's leave
them with a little bit of direction and
hope I get a lot of messages and just
because you know I'm out doing the music
and then races and then you know the
walking tours and just and people hit me
up they're like yo you know I mean close
to death sometimes with this stuff and I
and I just say look you know you got to
get that everybody says one day I'm
gonna do this one and I go you got to
flip the script on that [ __ ] and you
have to say day one and today is my day
one and I'm not gonna and just take it
day by day like they say even in the
rooms it's like you know take it day by
day one day at a time but but it you
know it's also those connections they
say people places and things like I know
a lot of them for that philosophy and I
think that that's the truth
and staying around positive people that
are doing you know positive things and
are also you know when I was getting off
crack I didn't go hang out with people
that [ __ ] had crack habits those
people almost got me murdered because I
wasn't I had issues as from a childhood
whatever so I succumbed to that so you
know get your day one say today I'm
gonna wake up I'm gonna replace all that
other [ __ ] with positive stuff somebody
told me that the other day I said every
time you want to [ __ ] get high drop
and do [ __ ] 50 pushups go [ __ ] run
go [ __ ] II could go read a book go
watch go do something else that's gonna
allocate that same time you were gonna
give in to your addiction to doing
something that's gonna be beneficial to
you and your life and that's that's
really you know my message and and to
reach out to people don't you know it
just costs my guitar player his life
because the embarrassment and trying to
hide what was going on you you know I
think in terms of the Four Agreements we
make assumptions and that's a problem we
assume people are gonna judge us we
assume we're gonna be looked down upon
but no you'd be quite surprised how many
people are out there that love you and
have compassion and you know you know
they were waiting for you to step
forward and inmate hey man I got a
[ __ ] problem and that's number one to
solving a problem you have to admit you
have one Mishka I'm gonna borrow a note
from you know from one of the things JJ
was talking about today and just say you
don't have to have the gun locked and
loaded in order to make the decision to
change your life it doesn't have to be
lowest ebb it doesn't have to be
blackest night you know at any point in
your life you're ever having a problem
with you know drinking too much using
drugs smoking eating just acting wrong
you know that there's always a way
forward and the
I love this concept of higher power I
think it's [ __ ] awesome the we can
the next time I come back we can just
talk about HAARP all right and and and
for me it's it's been the connection the
the connection between human beings and
that's the you know that's the only way
that I know how to like navigate this
[ __ ] quagmire is through connecting
with other people so so not alone
absolutely not alone and let me ask you
this what is it about connection that
gives you that feeling like that's where
you can find spirituality because you
can't put your finger on it right there
is no tangible thing about that but
there's something mystical that happens
through connecting with another human
being that provides that healing you
know what I was when I had my old van my
little Toyota previa I was driving down
the highway one day in New Jersey and I
was I pulled up next to this you know
Latino dude driving the exact same year
the same color I remember and I just I
honked and I and I did shave and a
haircut and he looked over at me and did
two bits I [ __ ] I was like just that
level of connection man just reaching
out and just being like are you getting
what I'm putting down you know and we
understood each other you know and like
if I you know if you're listening and
gotta go do a turkey bug that's all it
takes man right you can move mountains
for little things
yeah yeah I think you made an important
point which is it doesn't have to be the
blackest night and and I think there's a
lot of people who are suffering who
think well you know I'm not living on
the street or I'm not in jail or you
know I haven't gotten a DUI or whatever
it is you can always point to somebody
who's suffering more or somebody whose
condition is far more dire than your own
but the truth of the matter is if you
look in the mirror and you're honest
with yourself to recognize that the
elevators going down it's going to
continue to go down but you can step off
at any point that opportunity is
available to you in every single given
moment
it's harder to step off when you still
have things to lose when you hit that
rock bottom that's a blessing right like
then you're willing man because you'll
do anything it takes but that doesn't
have to be your situation and the truth
is that's not the case for most people
and to remain in the moment right to
stay in the day I think a lot of people
get caught up in future tripping my
objective ago to this thing next month
and there's no way I can do that sober a
wedding or whatever it's like you don't
have to worry about that man you just
got like five hours between now and when
your head hits that pillow do you think
you can make it until then without
picking up a drink that's it man yeah
that's it and you string those things
together I would supplement what both of
you guys have said by just saying that
it's important that you find somebody
that you can talk to you honestly like I
know you feel shameful you feel
embarrassed that same embarrassment that
you know basically killed you're killed
your bandmate you've got to find an
outlet for that so find somebody that
you feel like you can be honest with and
like open up and tell them what's going
on
shame can't survive the light and that
is the first step towards like wrestling
those demons into the ground definitely
love you guys man I'm glad we [ __ ]
love you both
thank you so much for 500 episodes dude
it's crazy massive accomplish thank you
and we're like we're all indebted and
the talent pool I mean I mean Cody look
at these guys yeah where's the p.m. a
book it should be back there it might be
in my no I'll bring it out I think it's
back in the music for [ __ ] there
there you go
yeah man seven years five hundred
episodes it feels like yesterday and
also feels like a hundred years but I
got a plug this yeah man if you want
[ __ ] that's the German edition you
got there
don't be cool listen to everybody who's
watching or listening I don't take your
attention for granted and this journey
that I've been on is solely the result
of you gifting me with your time and
your attention so much love and
appreciation to everybody out there who
took a chance on this show and has
become part of this audience that means
so much to me and it is your energy and
enthusiasm and engagement with what I do
that keeps me going so mad love and the
authenticity of what you do that's what
carries it on and I always say one thing
and it's that few people can smell
[ __ ] and I say the [ __ ] detector
you might be able to fool people and get
over on people but it's always who me
wants fool you can't be fooled no but
it's the [ __ ] detector and the
authenticity of this show and what you
do and you live what the [ __ ] you say
you're out there [ __ ] doing it and
like I always say Prabhupada set
examples better than precept and I don't
know too many people that set a better
example than what you do and how you
affect people and that comes across to
people they know they they can tell that
it's authentic it's real and you know
[ __ ] amazing 500 episode thanks for
having us yeah man yeah man
next time we'll thank you and next time
we'll do it in the cramped hotel room
that's right the small we have to do it
in Phoenix see this truck or something
all right love you guys peace
[Music]